last week myself and my friends got
together flexed our creative muscles and
drove some stuff what sort of stuff well
we took some stills from dragon ball
super and changed the style too
alright so just like last time myself
and my friends trev anime aj and
editor-san will be cycling through some
of the most iconic stills from the
series and well transforming them into
one of dragon ball z's various art
styles so who's drawing first
anime aj the first drawing on the
chopping block is the super saiyan god
debut from episode 9 of the dragon ball
super series the god form is an awkward
one to transform back into the days of
old it's a simple design with slim
features and rare eye design you can
simply bulk it up and add loads of
shading because that'll make it look
wrong which is why although incredibly
well drawn some of the god drawings in
dragon ball super broly weren't quite in
line with toriyama's design philosophy
for this form to try and avoid this aj
decided to try and channel an icon of
the industry's style instead katsuyoshi
nakatsuru nakatsuru is one of the
longest standing animators in the series
working on pretty much every single
iteration of the series including battle
of gods and super and serving as a
character designer for the boo arc and
gt his style at the time was very ahead
of its time which lends itself well to
the modern forms designs while also
maintaining that classic feel with its
approach to shading and hair shapes the
original piece of artwork from dragon
ball super is fine enough and largely
adheres to super's model sheets drawn by
tadayoshi yamamuro these sheets are
effectively the guidelines animators are
expected to adhere to when drawing the
characters however regrettably it's
those very character sheets that many
people including us have taken issue
with over the years but in this drawing
aj is working on it's clear he's after
fixing the various issues with the prior
design by coming up with an interesting
compromise and injecting some life back
into it and once we apply the filter the
classic effect is achieved perfectly
looking like something straight out of
the blue arc marks the super saiyan god
in all of its glory and continuing this
momentum into the resurrection f arc
comes
aj again something you might notice
about this still is that it doesn't
actually come from the dragon ball super
tv show but instead from the
resurrection f film from 2015 this is
really only because the resurrection f
arc of the tv series melted and doesn't
exactly represent the intended style
again much like the last video we're not
redrawing these pieces to necessarily
fix anything we're simply interested in
highlighting the differences between the
two errors and to give you insight into
where super's approach could have made
changes to evoke the aesthetics of old
this particular sequence comes from yuki
hayashi who animated part of the
spectacular goji to fight in dragon ball
super broly sporting incredible designs
that are a fair cry from what's on
display here this is because nowhere
shintani chose not to correct artwork
while hayashi's contribution in the
frieza film was totally redrawn by
tadayoshi yamamuro much like every frame
on that film by the way aj on the other
hand has decided to take a different
approach once again rolling with
nakatsuru style for the very same
reasons found in the super saiyan god
example much like goku black last week
trying to deal with modern bright and
glowy forms while maintaining that
classic look is incredibly hard those
kinds of heavily processed aesthetics
didn't really exist back in the day so
although the drawing is a perfectly
classic rendition that honors nakusudu
very well the final results don't quite
tickle the same nostalgic part of our
brains like the others have done at
least to us but we'll let you decide let
us know down below once again using his
trusty photoshop skills aj's transformed
this still into an approximation of what
dragon ball z may have offered this form
back in the day now that we have battle
of gods and resurrection f out of the
way it's time to start diving into some
new characters and tackling our next
drawing is
tread
it will be the case in some of the
drawings within this video that only my
nude alterations will be needed on a
given illustration with the majority of
the noticeable changes on those drawings
coming by way of the compositing
courtesy of aj and his filters but this
is not one of those drawings from the
ground up the very anatomical and
artistic philosophy in this drawing
needed to be reworked to grant the piece
a more refined and classic feel as
mentioned in the prior video the more
modern additions to the series beerus
whis cabba caulifla etc are a little on
the scrawny side although there are
exceptions akira toriyama has largely
moved away from the bulky designs seen
in the saiyan and frieza sagas now as
noted last week this isn't a complaint
but just another of the numerous changes
toriyama's style has seen over the years
thankfully this offers a unique
opportunity for the likes of cabba a
character we identified as perfect for
this sort of style shift trev is elected
to take reference from the likes of teen
gohan from the south saga while
implementing his older yamamuro art
style he's so adept at mimicking bulking
up the body shrinking the head and
adding some life to the clothes are just
some of the changes on an illustrative
level to this piece the most intense
changes however come in the way of the
color design throwing out the colors
from the super iteration and breathing
new life into the piece with a period
appropriate palette all that's left now
is to apply the filter and
there you have it buff boy kaba complete
with dbz aesthetics great job trev next
up for drawing
trev once more
as soon as frost was introduced in
episode 32 i knew at some stage in my
life our two paths would be drawn
together in this fashion pawn absolutely
intended and given that i got to give
his main form the old school treatment
in the last video i figured it was only
fair that trev got to try his hand at
this incarnation of the character in a
style that while both brilliant and
iconic is deceptively difficult to pull
off effectively ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the masaki sato section of
this video
[Music]
if you don't know about this legend of
the dragon ball industry then sit tight
because this is my personal favorite
style in all of the dragon ball series
for many people minora maeda is the name
that comes to mind when thinking of the
classic saiyan and frieza arcs of z but
contrary to popular belief most of the
spectacular drawings people attribute to
him actually come from asaki sado who
worked under him at studio junior which
means thankfully trev has some terrific
references of frieza drawn by sado
himself incredibly detailed collarbones
necks and thick rich line work are just
some of the many characteristics
associated with this man and trev
absolutely annihilated this challenge
lifting the colors from my piece last
week and there you have it all that's
left now is aj's filter
this is an incredibly impressive piece i
think it looks not only authentic but
offers the character a subdued menace i
thought he lacked in the super series
it's one of the many aspects of sato
style i adore and we are absolutely not
done with this style yet next up
me
episode 47 is one of the most impressive
episodes in super i think with one of
the strongest endings to a single
episode i've ever seen and while it's
iconic and perfectly on model it's also
about as modern yamamuro a drawing can
get without being super dragon ball
heroes and with me currently having a
craving only masaki sado can satisfy i
knew i had some extra creative energy to
expel on giving goku black everyone's
favorite edge boy the masaki sado
treatment masaki sado is responsible for
some of the best scenes in the series as
i mentioned in the last drawing and
thankfully his work on the third z movie
meant i had a million amazing references
of tireless to draw from for this other
evil goku design but and this is the big
but i find this style incredibly
difficult to draw i combed through this
series meticulously looking for
references like a kid with a where's
wally book and the footage that you're
looking at now reflects that very
process at numerous times i think i'm
finished only to go back and change
things drastically the next day this
piece took me three days of going back
and forth trying to iron down the style
making slight changes like with the face
and massive ones with the clothes this
piece was in every meaning of the phrase
a team effort and i honestly couldn't
have reached this point without aj trev
or editor san i'm very happy with how
this turned out and i even added some
fire effects in the style of the tree of
my film for added authenticity i hope
you like it and with the filter courtesy
of aj it really and truly looks like
something that came out decades ago i
wish i could say that this was the
toughest drawing i attempted in this
video but it was actually the easiest
time for me to rest now though next up
editor sound
introduced in episode 52 of dragon ball
super zamasu might seem like a character
prototypical of the super series but in
reality he actually follows relatively
closely in line with the same sort of
design philosophy the other kai's in z
did also canon or otherwise therefore
zamasu is an example of a design that
only required minor alterations to bring
it into a classic style and aesthetic
the body itself needed a greater level
of detail first and foremost with the
hands receiving most of the focus but by
far what needed the most attention was
the face the existing face is something
that was very
super for lack of a better term and as
such we need to dbzify it granting zamas
a slimmer more pronounced jaw sharper
features and a host of shading changes
it took her combined efforts to get the
face just right but eventually we all
settled on a look we were happy with
that to my eyes seems like something
you'd see in the android arc the body is
full of lovely loose folds and angles
evocative of the saiyan arc while the
face has the robust blockiness that
would come into play in the later cell
and early boo era it's an awesome hybrid
and all we gotta do now is add the
filter
looks perfect fittingly evocative of the
classic era of dragon ball z
next up
trev
yeah but first a quick word from our
sponsor
[Music]
super saiyan rose while i find it
difficult to understand narratively it's
still damn cool to look at despite
tackling it in the last video we thought
it would be fun to try it again since aj
wasn't super happy with the aura and
kesuke masunaga's style that he
replicated isn't exactly the most
representative of what dragon ball
looked like on a regular basis in
response we've decided to fall back on
that classic tadayoshi yamamuro's style
given this modern iteration of the
character is from the very same animator
we thought it would be interesting to
see what the character might look like
if we picked the same man again but
rewound his style back in time to the
boo arc after following a massively
successful stint in his debut effort as
a character designer for the first broly
film yamamuro later replaced minora
maeda as the character designer for all
the subsequent dragon ball z movies gone
were the rougher more rugged features
associated with the saiyan frieza and
cell sagas instead replaced by a softer
more contemporary approach that many
today associate with dragon ball z as
its defining aesthetic and when it comes
to this drawing the style being
attempted is very much trev's bread and
butter as an artist i'm convinced he
could produce stuff like this in his
sleep and he pretty much does it with
this right here amazing work trev and
with the filter
[Music]
it looks amazingly authentic for the
time period attempted and i think we
actually nailed the aura this time but
no time to waste next up is
editor san
no one does self-love quite like zamasu
no matter what form he's in whether that
be the regular green form goku or indeed
the sky and tackling his final piece in
this video we get to see a reimagining
of the fabled hug between
self-proclaimed gods one of the many
requests we received in the last video
was to tackle characters like beerus
whis jiren etc the thing is there's not
a whole lot you can do with those
designs to make them look
classic we can add some extra shading
much like yuya takahashi did in the
tournament of power but at the end of
the day it would very much be like
slapping an old coat of paint on and
calling it a day whereas with this piece
it very much offers us something to work
with and work with it he most definitely
did applying the same colors he used in
the prior zamas illustration we get a
nice reimagining of this bromance and
with the filter it looks even better i
love that transcends both time and style
apparently
next up
me tackling something a little more
ambitious than i first anticipated
episode 66 for many is one of the best
looking episodes in the series and
nestled within it sits this ethereal and
dreamlike illustration and i say
dreamlike because in reality it makes
absolutely no sense but who cares
because it looks awesome coming to us
courtesy of legendary mech animator ken
otsuka the scene and indeed the drawing
in question is very polished and pretty
so let's try to do some weird stylistic
stuff to it taday yoshimura is a name
that's been thrown around a lot during
this video everything from his less and
stellar antics as a character designer
for dragon ball super all the way to his
critically acclaimed approach with the
first broly movie and boo arcs material
but something many people don't give him
credit for are the skills he honed long
before he first came into the spotlight
during these eras you see tadayoshi
yamamuro didn't just show up randomly as
a movie character designer for the
series and chief animation director for
the boo arc but instead cut his teeth in
the series for many many years as an
in-between artist and eventually key
animator on the og dragon ball series
but it wasn't until namick that he
really started to come to life bringing
us scenes like goku's kaioken times 20
which is maybe my personal favorite
scene in the series it was here his work
was recognized and he was quickly
promoted to assistant animation director
before totally overtaking his superior
position once the android arc rolled
around while many might prefer his stuff
in the buu saga my favorite version of
his style can be seen during goku and
trunks's first meeting right after
frieza gets the old slicy slice i find
the shapes used here to be really
interesting with the way he would shade
under the cheekbones to be specifically
unique and pleasing to me so this
specific era of yamamuro was what i
decided on trying to mimic also i may or
may not have chosen this style first and
foremost because of the hair trunks
brandishes within it this style of hair
wasn't long for this world but it was in
my opinion the very peak of dragon ball
hair and while i know it's not super
saiyan rage hair you guys did get that
last week so this one's for me with this
piece the biggest challenge personally
was born out of what way i should try to
communicate the spirit bomb sword the
spirit bomb was never depicted as a
man-made weapon in the series before and
more often than not just a ball of light
and in the end the presentation i
settled on was indeed that of compromise
loosely based on the way krillin holds
the bomb during the saiyan arc it's
difficult to make something that wasn't
present in the original series look
classic when it itself is indeed a
modern creation or idea with that said
however the colours and shading were
what i was most happy with this piece
concerning and i think i just about
managed to get tadayoshu yamamuro's
early android arc style down in the end
all it needs now is that famous aj
treatment and
i was very happy with how this final
piece turned out and the backgrounds
chosen by aj really brought the scene to
life next up
trev with his final drawing the final
desperate but powerful push to eliminate
jiren at the end of dragon ball super
tournament to power and its final
episode is by every measure an iconic
image originally animated by yuya
takahashi this sequence was redrawn by
yamamuro himself and it's one that will
be remembered for a long time to come
and it's used even in promo art to this
day redrawn by yam himself twice
bringing him up to having drawn this
image a total of three times now and
while the changes made stylistically
won't be enormous here i think this
serves to highlight quite elegantly
where yamamuro's style has changed over
the years or more specifically where
they've not changed that much at all and
to show just how strong an effect the
lighting and colors chosen in the scene
can serve to devalue the artwork present
a particular issue we all had with the
original piece from super specifically
was how blown out the brightness from
the auras were this post-processing
issue has been prevalent throughout
super's run reaching a fever pitch
during the tournament of power wherein
we could hardly see what was going on in
some scenarios vegeta's power up and
goku's ultra instinct specifically
spring to mind in this instance and so
with this piece we wanted to ensure that
there was indeed brightness but not so
much that it would otherwise obstruct
the original drawing and i think trev
achieved that and with the filter we get
an idea of what this scene might have
looked like if it was given the classic
treatment back in the day next up and
with the final drawing
me goku and frieza's team up in the last
episode was for me not only a highlight
of the super series but was perhaps one
of the only times in the series where i
felt like it had elevated the material
that came before growing up the frieza
and goku fight in dragon ball z was one
that i honestly fell in love with
instantly and during that material i
came to learn that one man's style
stands out over all the others and that
man is masahiro shimanuki he's one of
the longest standing animators in the
entire series and even contributed his
own animation in the very episode this
image was taken from in super going into
this video i wanted to try and tackle
three distinct styles with goku black i
tried to go for masaki sato with future
trunks i aimed for more of a classic
yamamuro style but for this one while i
don't think it's the most iconic or
polished i think there's no style more
fitting for this occasion than masahiro
shimanuki's the style that very much
defined the very first time goku and
frieza fought will now be attempted by
me to depict their final moments
fighting alongside each other and let me
tell you this one was an absolute
nightmare on top of there being two
characters for me to draw i had to do so
in a style i never attempted before and
littered throughout these drawing
recordings are my trial and error
processes at numerous times i was
consulting friends starting over and
tweaking different aspects of this
drawing to try and get as close to the
style as i could to try and make the
characters look like they were during
their first fights opening moments with
this piece i found myself drawing into
the early hours of the morning and in
the end i think it turned out quite
faithful the shimanuki's old style and
with the filters added i can safely say
that i'm very happy with how it turned
out
in the end i couldn't have done this
once again without trev anime aj and
editor san links to all their socials
are in the description so if you haven't
checked them out i highly encourage you
to do so right now making these videos
was incredibly fun and i hope you had
some fun and maybe learn something here
and there too as always i've been told
not mark i'll see you all next week and
thank you so much for watching
[Music]
you